-Seth Meyers.
-It's so nice to be back.
-Yeah. You're looking sharp.
-Thank you, man.
-Looking good.
-Thank you.
-Do you miss me?
Seeing and talking to me
every day.
-I do.
We weirdly -- We overlapped
for two years on "SNL."
We weirdly spent more time
collaborating on this podcast.
It was the best.
-I had
such a great time doing it.
I mean, I know you
and I'm friends with you,
but really got to know you.
And we spent like 15 hours
together talking.
-It was, yeah,
I think the very fact
that we had to make this podcast
and it forced us all
to talk about ourselves,
it was a very cool thing
and I felt very lucky
to do it with you.
-Yeah, I agree.
Thank you, buddy.
It was us. It was me and you.
It was Jimmy Kimmel.
-It's not important.
It's not important who
the other people were.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right. Doesn't matter.
-It's you, me, and three guys.
It doesn't matter who they are.
-Yeah.
-Could be three nobodies.
It basically was.
[ Laughter ]
-We kind of got to know
what we were doing, though,
by the end.
-Yeah, but you were the best.
-No.
-Yeah. No, everybody --
Look, you hosted
the fifth episode.
-We all had to host an episode.
-Yes.
And so you hosted
"The Newlywed Game."
We were foolish enough.
We gave Jimmy all of
our wives' phone numbers.
-Yeah.
-Which never do.
If a dude's like, "Hey, I want
all your wives' numbers,"
we're like, "Hey, okay."
You'd be better off giving away
your Social Security number.
-I have everyone's wives'
numbers.
I thought it was interesting
because we're
all talk show hosts
and we're all luckily
very happily married man.
And we have families. I go,
"That could be a fun episode.
Let's talk to the wives
who actually see
how crazy we really are
and see how our answers match."
-Yeah, like
a "Newlywed Game" style.
It should have worked.
-Yes, it should have been that.
-Yeah, but it was --
It ended up
being something better.
-Dude, John Oliver
is laughing so hard.
I think he, like,
broke a rib or something.
-It was -- John Oliver --
you know, of all of us
maybe the most capable
of stoicism --
laughed so hard at the way
you phrased the questions
that he kept falling
out of the Zoom box.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, he was falling down.
-He would come back through
like a pendulum.
-Well, you know what?
What happened was because
I was like, alright,
I don't want to bother
the wives, you know,
but I wanted to ask them
the questions like,
"When did you first fall
in love" or whatever.
So I just wrote them in a text
and I just sent them texts
with not even really questions.
-You used a lot
of pronouns loosely.
-So didn't know if you were
talking about you or them.
-Yeah, the best one
in the first episode you --
because you just wrote to my
wife, "Pet name" question mark.
And now I think that my wife
should have assumed
you meant what pet names
we have for each other.
-So you were like, "I know what
it is. It's 'babe.'"
-Yeah. I thought our pet name
for each other is "babe."
I explained it to -- Long story.
-And I said, "I think your wife
misunderstood the question"
because I think she gave us
your actual pet name.
Your pet's name.
[ Laughter ]
-She texted Jimmy Frisbee,
which is our pet's name.
[ Laughter ]
And the funny part about that
is that would be the dumbest
question on "The Newlywed Game."
Like, imagine if you couldn't
match with your spouse
what the name of your pet is.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Like, that's not even like
you don't know each other.
You might not live together.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I think Colbert was like,
"This is turning into like
an Alzheimer's exam."
Like, who's the president?
-Who is? Yeah.
-What year is it?
-Yeah.
And then we went back
to the well,
which is a very dangerous
thing to do in comedy
because you had a lot
of questions you'd ask them
that we hadn't gotten to
in episode 5.
In episode 11, we did it again
and it was equally good
because you weren't allowed
to go back
and ask the questions better
because you had to use
the original answer.
-Yeah, the original bad answers
from the original question.
-Yeah.
-Questionnaire that I sent out.
-Also, my wife was --
let's be honest --
my wife took this
as an opportunity to do bits.
-What we devised from
interviewing your wife
is that she's trying
to kill you.
-Yeah, like, it was like,
"What's the hardest
you've laughed," And I'm like,
"Oh, that's funny.
Our kids said
this funny thing."
And then her answer was "the
time he fell out of a canoe."
[ Laughter ]
They were all like -- it was
like evil had befallen me.
And then she copped
to another answer
she gave you that
we didn't get to
that I think proves my point
that I'm about
to be knocked off.
-I sent a bunch of --
I sent a speed round.
We didn't get to all of these.
So I'm like, "Salty or sweet?"
Again, I didn't say who.
-Yeah.
-I didn't say the husbands
or the wives.
-Yeah.
-So people were
answering for themselves.
-Or the husband
or you never even knew.
Right.
-I, to this day,
don't know
what question I asked.
I don't know why I expected it.
But she said salty.
I think she meant her?
-I think she is a salty person.
Yeah.
-No, no, no, that's not what --
-Based on her answers, Jimmy.
-No. Okay, listen.
Morning person, then where
you proposed.
The fifth one I asked, I said,
"Big spoon or little spoon?"
-Yeah.
-I just thought
it'd be funny because --
-That's a good question.
-I think that'd be hilarious.
-My wife's answer
is not a funny answer.
Look what she wrote.
Knife.
[ Laughter ]
When I go missing, Jimmy,
go to that.
Send the police to my apartment.
-It was really funny.
Alexi, that was great.
-This is very good. Very salty.
-Very, very funny.
She was fan-- All the --
-She did.
I think she did a very good job.
I'm actually very proud of her
for her comedy choices.
-All the wives
were extremely funny.
And I go, "Wow, we're so lucky,
for God's sakes."
-Those were her --
The ones where she, the focus
was on her were
her two favorites,
and she didn't listen
to the other 10.
-[ Laughs ] I love her.
You know what?
I loved her because she popped
in one of the Zooms
wearing a
"Late Night with Jimmy" --
-That was also very hurtful.
We're doing a Zoom
and she has a "Late Night,"
not even a "Tonight Show,"
"A Late Night with Jimmy Fallon"
T-shirt from
when he had my show.
-I didn't have your show.
I had my show.
-Look, she's my wife!
[ Laughter ]
-I have her cellphone number.
-She came in wearing --
She showed it
to all the other hosts.
"Here I am
in my Jimmy shirt."
-Yeah. And then we started
talking about merch.
-Oh, yeah.
-In the NBC store.
-Yeah, this is --
Look, I brought proof
because I feel like --
I don't want to come off
as complainy on the podcast.
But here's the thing.
Jimmy and I both
have television shows.
They're both an hour long.
-Uh-huh.
-We should have the same amount
of merch in the NBC store.
-We're in this building
together.
-I had to do a collage to get
all the "Tonight Show" merch.
That's a "Tonight Show" --
Look at that.
There's a whole -- by the way,
second card, "Tonight Show."
"Late Night" merch, just like
one like barely attended wall.
[ Laughter ]
-That's not bad.
-Look, there's only one --
Thank you.
There's only one show --
There's only one show
that has less merch than me.
And it hasn't been
on the air for years.
That's it.
-Oh, that's fantastic.
I like "Saved by the Bell."
-Thank you.
-Yeah. So in your --
But I was saying to you,
I think that --
-You came up with a great idea.
You solved this problem.
-I think I did.
-Yeah.
-I said, because "Closer Look"
is one of your
biggest things you do
and the biggest hits
on your show.
People tune in for that.
You do a great job, by the way.
The whole, by the way, congrats.
The show is fantastic.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And you do a great job.
I go, "I think you should
have a T-shirt that says..."
-"It's time for."
-..."it's time for."
-In big letters.
This was your idea.
"It's time for"
and then here's the shirt.
In tiny little letters,
because we're going to do this,
in tiny little letters,
it'll say...
That says "A Closer Look."
-Can we zoom in?
It says "A Closer Look."
-Yeah.
It's got to be real small.
Judging by the crowd,
I don't know
if this is going to...
[ Laughter ]
This is going to work.
-Well, or they all need glasses.
I don't...
-But yeah.
Or you can even
just do "A Closer Look"
Just really small,
get rid of "it's time for."
-Yeah. I don't know.
It seems like --
-Or maybe in the middle.
But what is this thing?
-Based on --
Oh, this is we're going
to make this the tag.
It's going to say "Late Night
with Seth Meyers shirt
written by Jimmy Fallon."
[ Laughter ]
-That counts as your merch.
-We want to give you credit and
based on the audience reaction,
NBC says they're going to
order two.
[ Laughter ]
-Limited edition!
-If they sell,
if those two sell...
-If those two sell,
who knows
what's going to happen?
-Who knows
-More with Seth Meyers
when we come back, everybody.
"A Closer Look" T-shirt.